Messieurs chers collègues je vous
remercie d'être madame la rapporteur
donc nous nous retrouvons pour une
audition plénière à commission d'enquête
pénurie de médicaments
qui s'intitule celle-ci cette table
ronde regard croisé sur les pénuries de
médicaments vous êtes issus d'horizon
différentes et c'est ce qui nous
intéresse
donc aujourd'hui nous entendons
plusieurs associations organismes que
nous pourrions qualifier de grands
témoins voilà c'est ce qu'on attend de
vous des pénuries de médicaments et de
leurs conséquences que ce soit au niveau
de la prescription ou derrière pour la
prise en charge de d'un certain nombre
de pathologies nous avons jusqu'à
maintenant accueilli les constats et les
analyses des institutionnelles donc la
NSM
l'arrache le CEPS la DGS donc pour
planter un peu le décor des différentes
institutions présentes sur ce sujet
c'est aujourd'hui les acteurs de terrain
donc les usagers prescripteurs des
médicaments issus de divers secteurs
médicaux que nous entendrons afin de
vérifier la convergence ou la divergence
des constats qui nous ont été fournis
par les institutionnels et des réponses
qui nous ont été faites donc sont
présents autour de la table professeur
Pierre al baladejo
c'est ça c'est bien prononcé
président de la société française
d'anesthésie et de réanimation votre
association lafar c'est donner pour
mission de promouvoir la recherche et
les bonnes pratiques dans le domaine de
l'anesthésie et la réanimation ce n'est
hélas pas la première fois que vous
tirez la sonnette d'alarme sur le sujet
des pénuries de médicaments puisque dès
2011 vous dénonciez je cite
l'intensification des ruptures déjà
récurrentes mais aussi ce que l'on voit
arriver la rue commerciale pour raison
économique touchant des produits
indispensables et sans alternatives le
constat reste le même aujourd'hui ou par
manque de matières premières vous nous
direz si c'est prédictions ce sont
vérifiées et nous donnerait votre
appréciation sur les mesures qui ont été
au nom prises pour y remédier madame
Sophie beau-père et moi délégué général
uNICANCER qui fait derrière les 18
centres de lutte contre le cancer l'une
des missions de ces centres et de
permettre au plus grand nombre de
personnes touchées par le cancer d'avoir
accès à des soins innovants et de
qualité notamment par une politique
d'achat spécifique par des programmes de
recherche et ces cliniques et par la
mutualisation des connaissances et des
expériences vous pourrez nous parler des
pénuries qui frappent aujourd'hui
plusieurs traitements anticancéreux
essentiels et nous préciser l'important
des pertes de chances qui ont résulte
pour les patients et vous nous diront
aussi si le système français garantit
selon vous un bon accès aux médicaments
innovants qu'il s'agisse de leur
autorisation ou de leur tarification
Monsieur Pierre Chirac rédacteur de
prescrire édité par l'Association mieux
prescrire prescrire ces données pour
mission d'apporter une information de
qualité aux professionnels de santé dans
l'exercice de leur activité notamment en
ce qui concerne les médicaments
vous publiez notamment un palmarès des
médicaments importants de réels progrès
thérapeutiques et faites une revue de
nouveaux traitements des nouveaux
traitements disponibles vous pourrez
évoquer devant nous l'impact de
l'innovation sur l'accès aux soins et
nous éclairer sur le différentiel
thérapeutique réels entre médicaments
innovants et médicaments mature l'objet
de beaucoup de questionsnements
peut-être pourrait vous aussi évoquer
l'intérêt et les dangers de la
substitution d'un traitement par un
autre parfois incontournable dans un
contexte de tension sur
l'approvisionnement sujet auquel nous
avons été tout récemment confrontés le
professeur Luc frima président de la
Société Francophone nécrologie dialyse
et transplantation la sfndt a un
contexte par ailleurs difficile d'accès
à la dialyse fortement compliquée
s'ajoute la pénurie d'un traitement
anti-rogé apportant le Bella acep
vous pourrez nous présenter plus en
détail ces cas de rupture
d'approvisionnement et la manière dont
les professionnels peuvent y trouver des
solutions ce qui évidemment n'est pas
d'une très grande simplicité et enfin
Madame
ivani cailler fondatrice et
vice-présidente de renalou renalo on dit
je crois
association de patients atteints de
maladies rénales qui gère notamment un
site internet de partage d'informations
votre association vise à assurer
l'information et l'accompagnement des
patients notamment sur les traitements
disponibles ou qu'ils ne sont pas et à
relayer les difficultés rencontrées vous
pourrez nous en dire plus sur l'impact
très concret des pénuries sur la santé
publique et la perte de chances et sur
les mesures qui sont prises pour y
remédier sur les différents points
évoqués nous souhaitions que vous
puissiez témoigner de manière concrète
de vos expériences et des situations que
vous rencontrez au quotidien dans vos
situations héros le respectifs vous
aurez chacun tour à tour la parole pour
un propos introductif d'environ cinq
minutes puis madame Laurence Cohen
rapportera de notre commission d'enquête
vous posera des questions plus précises
nous vous demanderons également de bien
vouloir nous retourner des réponses
écrites en complément de cette audition
et ainsi que tout ce que vous souhaitez
utile de porter à notre connaissance et
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et elle fera l'objet
d'un compte rendu publié
avant de vous donner la parole nous
sommes donc en commission d'enquête et
je vous rappelle qu'un frotter le Moyen
Âge devant notre commission d'enquête
est passible des plaines prévues aux
articles 300 434-13 434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal je vous invite
chacun à votre tour à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
en levant la main droite et en disant je
le jure
le professeur
madame beaupère
professeur
très bien je vous remercie et donc je
donne la parole à la rapporteur de
Laurence Cohen ah non je vais vous
laisser d'abord faire vos propos
liminaires excusez-moi
donc dans l'autre que vous souhaitez
[Rires]
cirque on fait dans un sens ou dans
l'autre comme vous le souhaitez
je vous prie de m'excuser je serais
obligé pour une autre audition de vous
quitter en cours de route et donc je
serai remplacé par
Alexandra pour chaud au fond de qui est
vice-présidente
je lirai à votre attention tous vos
propos
madame la Présidente
et Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
merci de prendre au sérieux cette
question des pénuries des médicaments et
d'avoir invité prescrire pour témoigner
donc pour ce qui concerne prescrire en
fait nos premiers articles sur les
pénuries de médicaments date à de 1999
et nous en avons publié une centaine
depuis donc il ne s'agit pas du tout
d'un problème nouveau on pourrait même
dire qu'il s'agit d'un problème ancien
et prévisible dans l'aggravation était
prévisible donc tant mieux si
effectivement en France et au niveau
européen actuellement il y a un certain
nombre de d'initiatives pour essayer de
trouver des solutions à ce problème mais
ce problème malheureusement était
prévisible et il n'a fait que s'aggraver
les nombres de médicaments en rupture de
stock n'a fait que sa lourdir des
médicaments de plus en plus importants
posant des problèmes considérables pour
certains patients et posant des
problèmes aussi pour des soignants qui
passent de plus en plus de temps à
essayer de pallier assez pénurie
il se trouve que donc il y a juste
quelques jours le
groupe pharmaceutique de l'Union
européenne a publié comme ils le font
chaque année une enquête sur auprès de
29 États membres de cette union donc
l'Europe au sens large et
ce qu'on voit très clairement c'est ce
sont les conséquences alors les
formations passent 7 heures par semaine
à essayer de résoudre ces problèmes de
pénuries ce qui est déjà pas forcément
la meilleure utilisation de leurs
compétences et d'ailleurs et commencer à
demander à être rémunéré pour cela on
voit les conséquences enchaînent des
pénuries mais surtout ce qui est
important dans leur rapport c'est
montrer que et bien
dans 27 pays sur 29
93% donc des des groupements
pharmaceutiques interrogés considèrent
que
sa présente des des cas de détresse pour
les patients ils ont été confrontés à
ces problèmes là 90% des interruptions
de traitement
des traitements sous optimaux dans 58%
des cas des erreurs de médicamenteuses
dans 35% des cas des effets indésirables
dans 21% des cas voire des morts dans
14% des cas dans dans les différents
pays donc voilà le problème pratique le
plus important c'est bien pour les
patients le fait de pas avoir accès à
des médicaments essentiels pour eux de
devoir vous l'avez mentionné tout à
l'heure la question de la substitution
oui des fois on peut substituer pour
avec des médicaments qui sont
équivalents des fois ils ne sont pas
équivalents pour un grand nombre de
raisons soit ils n'ont pas la même
balance bénéfices risque soit ils n'ont
pas le même dosage soit il y a des
problèmes de d'information parce que ça
va être dans une langue différente enfin
bref tout ça entraîne des problèmes pour
les patients et je pense que c'est ça
qui motive le plus les responsables
politiques de faire quelque chose c'est
à dire il y a vraiment des patients en
détresse
les soignants que ce soit les médecins
prescripteurs qui perdent du temps à
essayer ou soit qui prescrit des
médicaments dont il s'aperçoivent qu'en
fait ils ne sont pas disponibles ou qui
essaient de chercher des alternatives
des pharmaciens aussi qui sont obligés
de trouver les alternatives à l'hôpital
ou en ville bref la situation de terrain
et de plus en plus insupportable et
malheureusement ça fait plus de 20 ans
que ça dure que ce soit pour des
médicaments ou des vaccins il est
vraiment grand temps de trouver des
solutions pérennes qui prennent en
compte l'ensemble de la problématique et
probablement et je m'arrêterai là pour
les exposer des mineurs ce sera au
niveau européen mais il faut absolument
que des États membres et pourquoi pas la
France soit leader pour pousser l'Europe
à adopter des mesures qui soient
pérennes et efficaces merci
merci mesdames messieurs d'avoir invité
donc la société francophone de
néphrologie dialyse transplantation à
cette audition
nous sommes très reconnaissants de
d'avoir invité une société savante qui
représente une maladie chronique vous
avez parlé de crise de criticité
effectivement ça peut se poser à un
moment donné quand on est face à face
avec son patient
ou bloc opératoire en consultation mais
il faut pas oublier la problématique des
maladies chroniques qui sont des
maladies qui vont atteindre les patients
pendant 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans une très
longue période de de leur vie et c'est
un petit peu ce témoignage là que je
souhaite vous apporter aujourd'hui alors
madame la Présidente vous avez parlé
d'emblée de la problématique du
médicament bellatasept qui est un
médicament donc immunosuppresseur
utilisé en transplantation rénale la
transplantation rénale c'est 45000
patients en en France avec 55000
patients dialysés ce sont ces 90000
patients représentent le stade le plus
avancé de la maladie rénale chronique
lorsque les reins sont détruits qu'ils
ne fonctionnent plus mais on estime
aujourd'hui quand population 8% de la
population française est concernée par
la maladie rénale chronique ce qui
représente probablement autour de 5
millions de de patients donc le si je
reviens sur le bellatasept c'est un
médicament qui existe depuis une
quinzaine d'années qui est utilisée en
France chez environ 2500 patients la
France est le pays d'Europe qui
l'utilise le plus bien bien avant
d'autres pays ce qui témoigne finalement
de variations dans son utilisation dans
son indication comme c'est souvent le
cas dans notre spécialité où la
dimension de la personnalisation du
traitement l'adaptation aux besoins du
patient à l'équilibre entre les
la sécurité et
omniprésente pour ce qui concerne ce
médicament il est en rupture déjà
annoncé depuis plusieurs mois et aiguë
depuis deux trois mois je dois souligner
la place vraiment efficace de la NSM
pour gérer ce cette crise donc nous
avons été invités à
comment dire proposer trois le nom de
trois professionnels avec notre société
la société francophone de
transplantation trois autres
professionnels pour constituer un comité
d'experts qui a donc mis sur pied une
fiche qui est à la disposition des des
soignants sur le terrain pour poser
l'indication du médicament et donc par
le biais du laboratoire savoir si
l'indication peut être retenue ou pas
donc cette ce comité il s'est réuni
depuis le début du mois de janvier moi
je ne suis pas dans le comité mais comme
président de la société savante je aussi
pour réunion donc
d'explication avec l'information avec la
NSM nous avons des informations très
précises on peut souligner que
actuellement il y a en fait avec cette
organisation il reste du médicament
disponible donc on trouve un certain
équilibre et on a l'impression que on va
probablement réussir à passer le cap
d'ici quelques mois avec une
organisation qui est qui est efficace je
voudrais profiter de la deuxième partie
de mon temps de parole pour
souligner d'autres dimensions par
exemple il y a un médicament qui
s'appelle le bactrim qui est un
antibiotique historique dans sa solution
buvable qui fabriquée en France et donc
le taux de remboursement actuellement du
médicament est très inférieur au coût de
production ce médicament est la
propriété aujourd'hui d'un laboratoire
belge emedica qui a racheté le le
produit au laboratoire Roche et donc le
la France rembourse le médicament moitié
moins que que la totalité des autres
pays européens donc quand on c'est un
médicament qui peut se substituer aux
formes sous forme de comprimés sous
forme de et qui donc sous forme soluble
solution buvables peut-être vraiment
nécessaire en particulier pour les
enfants et donc se priver de ce
médicament
et donc ce qu'il faut souligner c'est
que le
comment dire la demande de d'un
remboursement adapté à déjà suivi tout
le process CESP en particulier avec une
fin de nos recevoir donc on nous dit que
c'est pas possible de de rembourser ce
médicament puisqu'il ne l'est
actuellement ce qui fait qu'on a un
risque de rupture qui est très
artificiel puisqu'en fait le médicament
produit en France va être exporté vers
les pays qui le rebord rembourse plus
donc c'est je pense c'est c'est
probablement assez simple de résoudre
cette difficulté enfin je termine en
insistant sur le fait que
la dimension de gestion de cette pénurie
pour ce qui concerne les maladies
chroniques donc c'est plusieurs millions
de patients il faut vraiment avoir une
action de prévention notre pays est à la
traîne pour la prévention on essaie ici
de résoudre un problème aigu sur la
maladie à son stade le plus avancé mais
il faut parallèlement faire un effort
sur la prévention qui par exemple pour
ce qui concerne le dépistage de la
maladie rénale chronique en population
la France c'est 25% le Royaume-Uni
66%. pourquoi est-ce que nous ne
réussissons pas à dépister diagnostiquer
précocément la maladie pour mettre en
oeuvre des mesures de néphroprotection
efficaces qui vont permettre de diminuer
efficacement le recours au traitement
par dialyse et et par greffe donc
faisons cet effort à l'échange de notre
pays c'est quelque chose que la sfndt
demande depuis plusieurs mois
voilà juste peut-être encore un petit
mot pour souligner qu'on est centré
médicament mais notre spécialité est en
très grande tension du point de vue du
dispositif médical
la dialyse l'hémodialyse se fait par un
fistule artério veineuse un dispositif
créé par chirurgicalement mais dans j'ai
30 40% des patients c'est pas possible
de créer cet abord vasculaire on doit
avoir recours à des cathéters que
fait-on quand il n'y a plus de cathéter
que fait-on quand il n'y a plus de
médicaments pour déboucher les cathéter
quand ils sont bouchés
que fait-on quand il y a de la pression
internationale sur le blé le maïs qui
servent aussi à fabriquer les concentrés
de dialyse vous voyez c'est c'est un
puzzle où il y a vraiment beaucoup
beaucoup de pièces l'annéephrologie et
donc je vous remercie de nous donner la
parole aujourd'hui et permettre de
souligner tout cela
merci de nous pouvoir nous permettre de
participer à cette audition évidemment
les tensions et les ruptures de
médicaments non-chologies sont un sujet
de préoccupation majeur pour pour unique
cancer qui représente les centres contre
le cancer mais évidemment pour pour
aussi les associations qui représentent
les patients
concrètement le sujet il est bien sûr
multifactoriel je dirais il a toute la
là il est présent en toute la chaîne de
des molécules c'est à dire des nouvelles
molécules puisqu'il y a des
problématiques vous avez évoqué
concernant l'accès précoce concernant la
recherche clinique jusqu'aux molécules
plus anciennes et j'y reviendrai et donc
ces problématiques elles sont elles
concernent l'ensemble en fait des
molécules qui sont qui sont utilisées
alors les centres de lutte contre le
cancer ils ont la chance d'être
regroupés pas seulement en fédération
mais aussi en groupement de coopération
sanitaires et donc ils ont une centrale
d'achat commune avec un marché des
médicaments qui est commun en 1800 et
qui est donc un marché qui permet
d'avoir des discussions avec avec les
laboratoires enfin dans le cas des
marchés qui sont passés on peut
travailler du coup étroitement il y a
200 médicaments en fait qui sont
regroupés dans le marché mais cependant
malgré cette organisation structurée en
2022 pour vous donner une illustration
il y a eu 27 molécules qui étaient
impactées par des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dans le cadre de
notre marché 27 sur sur 200 soit très
ennemis vous voyez soit dit un peu plus
de 10%, 50% étaient contingentés 50%
étaient en rupture alors en travaillant
avec la laboratoire on a pu faire en
sorte que ces ruptures n'est pas
d'impact si vous voulez sur les centres
on a eu un travail de coordination
d'échange et de travail en amont qui
nous a permis de pouvoir retrouver des
alternatives notamment quand cela a été
possible mais enfin il y a quand même
une partie des molécules qui étaient
contingentées en tout cas il y avait pas
de d'alternative donc c'est quand même
quelque chose qui reste compliqué alors
même que nous sommes on va dire très
organisé sur sur le sujet ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
effectivement
l'accès aux molécules innovantes alors
c'est pas les ruptures à proprement
parler mais je tiens quand même à
souligner que il y a des difficultés qui
persistent concernant l'accès précoce il
y a eu beaucoup de d'articles récemment
ces dernières semaines sur le sujet ou
des oncologues de toutes structure on
pris des positions et alerter sur les
difficultés qui pouvaient qui pouvaient
rencontrer liés aux modalités
d'évaluation de la chaise qui pourtant a
fait évolué ces modalités mais qui reste
quand même encore insuffisamment adapté
en fait à l'évolution même des molécules
et avec des essais de phase 3 des essais
endomisés qui sont demandés qui ne
peuvent pas être réalisés puisque les
molécules sont de plus en plus
spécialisé et concerne un petit effectif
de patients et donc nous on plaide
vraiment sur l'utilisation des données
de vie réelle ça avait été évoqué dans
le cadre du psy et ça c'est qu'un un
sujet très important parce que là on
parle même de l'accès à à des molécules
anémolicules innovantes et puis il y a
il y a un troisième problème je dirais
on a quand même des propositions un
message je pense qu'on reviendra dans le
cas des échanges il y a un troisième
problème là qui est qui aiguë et qui
s'est finalement accusé qui concerne des
molécules plus anciennes
là aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
fédérations et ont d'ailleurs
extrêmement préoccupé par un sujet qui
concerne un radiation en fait des
médicaments qui sont dans la liste des
molécules onéreuses ce système de
radiation il existe depuis plusieurs
années il était il était assez clair
concrètement si les prix des molécules
onéreuses étaient inférieures à 30% du
tarif du séjour
ces molécules n'étaient plus dans la
liste des molécules onéreuses mais
basculer dans le tarif du séjour qui
était et sortait de la liste des
molécules onéreuses il y avait donc un
mécanisme financier qui était clair et
là dans le cadre de la loi de
financement la sécurité sociale 2023 il
y a eu une liste de molécules qui a été
produite qui concernait beaucoup des
Antilles des anticancéreux et il nous a
été annoncé en février que et bien non
seulement ces molécules étaient radiées
mais qu'il n'y aurait pas de mécanisme
financier qui serait prévu pour pouvoir
les financer pour les établissements
donc l'ensemble des fédérations
et à comment dire c'était mute ce sujet
et on a eu des discussions ces derniers
jours et là on nous a annoncé qu'on
aurait un mécanisme
financier compensatoire mais seulement
pour un an et en fait ça concerne quand
même des les molécules onéoses qui sont
utilisées
pour les chimiothérapies en achadés et
puis aussi des molécules qui sont
utilisées en hématologie et j'attire
quand même l'attention sur le fait que
ça c'est pas ça ça risque ça peut
entraîner en plus un risque de
restriction de l'accès aux molécules et
en plus c'est quand même paradoxal
puisque c'est des molécules dont le prix
justement et relativement bas et comme
il n'y a pas de mécanisme financier qui
est qui est prévu il y a un risque
finalement que ces molécules soient
moins prescrites par un certain nombre
de structures donc là il y a un vrai
problème parce que on est ce mécanisme
tel qu'il est prévu
à présent en 2023 risque de générer de
nouvelles
pénuries de nouvelles problématiques
d'accès il y a d'ailleurs des sujets
aussi sur les dispositifs médicaux mais
là je parle de sujets qui concerne qui
concerne la cancérologie donc c'est
pourquoi effectivement nous pensons
qu'il faut un pilotage global
tout à fait compris l'histoire des
molécules onéreuses alors la liste c'est
vrai que c'était qu'est-ce que ça
implique la liste
heureuse après vous avez dit elles sont
pas et après faut une compensation
financière alors qu'elle écoute moins
cher par définition à vous explique le
sujet il y a des critères pour
déterminer quels sont les molécules qui
sont les plus chères onéreuses et qui
sont qui se sont pas les plus chers
voilà le critère qui fait qu'on radie ça
c'est depuis plusieurs années les
molécules de la liste c'est quand on
détermine quels sont inférieurs coût est
inférieur à 30% du coût du séjour et la
conséquence du fait qu'elle soit radiée
de la liste c'est quoi alors jusqu'à
présent ces dernières années quand elles
étaient radiées de la liste il y avait
un financement qui était prévu puisque
le tarif du séjour
vous voyez par exemple vous avez un
séjour
on est en tarification à l'activité
encore normalement il y a le tarif d'un
séjour plus une molécule onéreuse si
vous radier la molécule de la liste
parce qu'elle est inférieure à 30% du
coût du séjour le séjour a remboursé en
plus le séjour jusqu'à présent était
majoré c'est à dire
et là ce n'est plus le cas donc en fait
on radis de manière très sèche en
février quand même 2023 pour une année
des molécules
sans donner de moyens financiers
compensés à toi aux établissements pour
les financer ça le met en difficulté
financière
exactement et pour des structures par
exemple comme des achats des encore pour
les 102 contre le cancer c'est pas la
même mais quand même c'est des choses
qui peuvent représenter un million
d'euros par an pour un établissement par
exemple et
en fait du coup il n'y a pas toujours de
substitut il y a pas toujours il y a pas
de choses on peut pas forcément trouver
de substitut et j'attire quand même
l'attention que ça n'incite pas
forcément à diminuer les prix puisque
effectivement quand on diminue les prix
après pour les labos
[Musique]
est bien le médicament n'est plus dans
la liste des molécules onéreuses et donc
cela est une problématique nouvelle je
dirais puisque là du coup suite à notre
intervention ce qui a été décidé c'est
qu'il y aurait un financement en
dotation aide à la contractualisation
mais non pérenne transitoire pour un an
ce qui ne laisse pas place à de
solutions très claires un an après et
cela en fait et je pense est générateur
de nouvelles problématiques
merci beaucoup pour l'invitation elle va
présidente le rapporteur mesdames les
sénatrices et messieurs les sénateurs
dans la société française d'anesthésie
réanimation c'est une société savante
des professionnels de l'anesthésie de la
réanimation pour vous donner le contexte
du côté anesthésie donc il y a 12000
médecins anesthésistants animateurs
11000 infirmiers anesthésistes du côté
des actes d'anesthésie nous produisons
nous associons à 12 millions d'actes par
an qui couvrent toute la chirurgie pour
moitié mais aussi c'est très important
de le noter la médecine
interventionnelle cardio logis
interventionnelle endoscopie etc côté
réanimation deux tiers des réanimateurs
en France sont anesthésistes animateurs
donc comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure madame la Présidente l'émission
c'est principalement formation recherche
mais aussi c'est important beaucoup de
production de référentiel de référentiel
pour justement cadrer les différentes
pratiques et donc les prescriptions de
médicaments alors pourquoi notre
spécialité est aussi vulnérable
vis-à-vis des pénuries et bien parce que
la majorité de nos médicaments sont les
médicaments matures très vieux très
simples vraiment pas cher et ils sont
administrés volontiers par voie
intraveineuse et c'est un des facteurs
justement qui augmentent le risque de
pénurie et nous avons aussi une partie
qui est de l'anesthésie pédiatrique en
particulier et comme vous le savez les
médicaments à destinés pédiatriques ont
aussi particulièrement vulnérables en
termes de tension et de pénurie alors je
vais pas remonter à 2008 pour vous
donner toute l'histoire des pénuries
auxquelles on a été confronté mais
quelques exemples les farines plutôt des
médicaments issus de la biologie les
paris
issus de l'intestin de port comme vous
le savez et d'ailleurs actuellement nous
avons des soucis encore une fois avec
les paris puisque on est susceptible de
d'avoir des épidémies de des épidémies
porcines qui vont modifier la production
de ces médicaments alors l'antidote de
l'héparine c'est la protamine alors la
protamine c'est issue du sperme de
saumon
et il se trouve que la seule ferme qui
produisait du saumon c'était un
Fukushima donc on a en fait des
situations qui sont de pénurie ou de
tension d'approvisionnement qui sont
liées à des catastrophes climatiques
catastrophes industrielles et donc ils
sont absolument pas prévisibles ça c'est
pour les médicaments biologiques et
beaucoup de nos médicaments donc sont
issus de la synthèse je vais vous
connaissez mieux certainement mieux les
mécanismes mais néanmoins il y a des
médicaments extrêmement critiques qui
sont d'utilisation rares qui sont aussi
vulnérables je prends un exemple celui
du d'entrelen le d'entrelen c'est le
médicament qui nous permet de sortir des
patients qui font une complication
extrêmement rare un effet indésirable
extrêmement rare des gaz d'anesthésique
s'appelle l'hyperthermie maligne et le
d'entrelen a été à plusieurs reprises en
tension d'approvisionnement et pour
laquelle donc il y a eu des
modifications particuliers de date de
péremption qui nous permettait de faire
de garder nos stocks en fait donc vous
voyez on a des situations qui sont
extrêmement finalement classiques mais
multiple
est-ce que ça a des conséquences sur les
patients la réponse est oui de plusieurs
façons
c'est rarement de la pénurie pure c'est
à dire absence totale de médicaments
mais de
conséquences qui sont l'organisation des
soins les soins sont complexes imaginer
une réanimation avec des infirmiers qui
préparent des médicaments il faut une
homogénéité dans les procédures dans les
process de préparation et lorsqu'on
change où on substitue un médicament on
se retrouve avec des médicaments qui
sont de concentrations différentes de
pharmacocinétiques différentes et ce qui
pose un problème dans l'organisation et
qui fait le lignes de l'erreur
médicamenteuse dans sa plus grande
conception vous savez que la densité du
soin en anesthésie en réanimation fait
que il y a un risque d'erreur
médicamenteuse que un de nos comités qui
s'appelle le comité analyse et maîtrise
du risque
essaye de travailler depuis de
nombreuses années en proposant des
recommandations des référentiels mais
aussi en collaborant en particulier avec
la NSM pour essayer de sécuriser les
processus qui impliquent l'utilisation
des médicaments et donc le premier point
sur lequel je vous a insisté c'est
essayer de faire en sorte que il y ait
une fluidité dans la transfert
d'information entre les agences et les
professionnels souvent c'est notre
pharmacien qui nous dit attention il y a
une pénurie de et on reçoit la LED de la
NSM nous disant la semaine d'après alors
pas de critique sur la NSM il faut un
boulot formidable mais il y a un
problème d'information et de
structuration justement de cette
information qui nous permet nous de
réfléchir à comment est-ce qu'on peut
modifier nos soins nos processus au vu
des crises qui se produisent
donc deux points donc impact sur
l'organisation des soins et risque de
prévention d'erreurs médicamenteuses je
vous ai souligner le rôle des
pharmaciens qui sont en fait nos
partenaires
dans cette affaire là au CHU de Grenoble
où je travaille c'est un plein temps de
pharmacie qui s'occupe de des pénuries
et de la gestion des pénuries
alors déjà en 2018 2019 lafar a v
produit une liste de médicaments alors
cette liste de médicaments j'ai un peu
de problème de sémantique parce que on
peut l'appeler critique on peut
l'appeler essentiel prioritaire mais il
y a un problème de sémantique parce que
on ne veut pas que ces listes soient
utilisées pour une gestion de pharmacie
qui serait pas dans l'objectif justement
de ces listes là ces listes étaient
faites pour bien porter l'attention sur
des médicaments particulièrement
critiques très vulnérables pour lesquels
on ne peut absolument pas travailler
cette liste a été produite pour
l'anesthésier pour la réanimation entre
2019 et 2018 et 2020 et transmise à la
NSM et donc pendant covid pour nous ça a
été travaux pratiques
puisque les cinq médicaments
contingentés proposent folles midazolam
les trois curare ont été évidemment les
plus impactés ce qui nous a permis et ça
je pense que c'est très important de
travailler avec la Direction générale de
la santé avec la mécanisme qui
s'appelait boucle réa qui permettait
semaine après semaine de voir l'état des
stocks et les relations avec les
sociétés savantes donc il y avait pas
que la SFAR il y avait aussi la spielf
pour les anti-infectieux il y avait la
SRLF pour la réanimation médicale la
SFPC pour la pharmacie clinique et
d'autres et les discussions étaient
extrêmement intéressantes à la fois
surprenante pour
parce qu'on pensait que notre métier
était connu de tous mais non en fait non
et que donc la première étape ça a été
de revoir de faire une revue de toutes
les molécules possibles
et dans cette dans cette effort-là
on s'aperçu que effectivement enfin on
le savait mais que on crée la
dégradation du soin au fur et à mesure
de la de la de la dénomination des
médicaments qui quelquefois ressortaient
de nos vieux manuels d'anesthésie et qui
ont été pourtant
utilisés par la DGS pour essayer de
trouver des moyens en cas de pénurie
majeur de propofols en particulier une
midazole dire de médicaments sédatif
donc on a ressorti des vieux médicaments
comme le pain total ou le gamma wash qui
sont des médicaments qu'on utilise plus
pourquoi on les utilise plus parce que
ça correspond plus du tout à
l'organisation des soins dans lesquels
on se trouve actuellement avec
l'ambulatoire la réhabilitation rapide
après chirurgie nous avons aussi
participé au à la discussion autour du
contingentes ces molécules en faisant
bien attention et en alertant la DGS que
il n'y avait pas que la réanimation pour
l'utilisation de ces médicaments là mais
aussi la réalisation des gestes de
chirurgie ou de médecine internationale
urgent que soit la cancérologie les
urgences la traumatologie même si
beaucoup de ces pathologies enfin en
tout cas la traumatologie avait beaucoup
baissé avec la avec la le confinement
pour terminer donc
avoir un nouveau médicament
d'importation dans les services créer
comme je vous l'ai dit un problème
d'organisation je vous montre ici une
affiche qui a été faite par les
infirmières anesthésistes de mon service
pour montrer pour essayer de
sensibiliser les infirmiers et les
professionnels sur l'arrivée d'un
médicament importé donc c'était du
propofol chinois
d'une qualité équivalente il n'y a pas
de souci sur la qualité mais pour vous
indiquer en quoi est-ce que ça pose un
problème de risque d'erreur
médicamenteuse c'est que le label était
uniquement en chinois avec en tout petit
propofol ici vous avez l'ampoule c'est
la taille exacte de l'ampoule vous voyez
pas du tout donc j'ai la version
brésilienne si vous voulez donc avec
beaucoup d'humour nos équipements
réussis à gérer ses affaires là mais
pour nous c'était une pression en termes
de modification d'organisation
pour finir nous avons été recontactés
par la Direction générale de la santé
Monsieur François Bruno pour justement
essayer de de produire une liste je
pense que c'est un sujet qui est
important une liste de médicaments pour
lequel on pourrait confronter la
criticité industrielle c'est-à-dire y
a-t-il facilité ou pas à produire ces
médicaments jugés essentiels par les
professionnels et l'implication des
sociétés savantes extrêmement
importantes à ce sujet là
il a été évoqué l'utilisation de la
liste OMS ou la liste de la FDA en fait
quand on regarde ces listes là elles ne
correspondent pas du tout à la pratique
française et et donc il y a des
anomalies en fait dans ces listes donc
autant créer nos propres listes qui
correspondent à des listes ISO soin
c'est-à-dire pour garder la qualité et
la sécurité des soins que nous
prodiguons actuellement voilà je vous
remercie
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs merci
beaucoup de votre invitation et de votre
souhait d'entendre également la voix des
patients qui sont concernés par ces
pénuries donc renalou est une
association de patients atteints d'une
maladie rénale insuffisant rénaux
dialysée et greffé et aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler du sujet qui nous
occupe au plan de l'actualité depuis un
certain temps qui est la pénurie de
bellatasept donc le bellatasep c'est un
anti rejet et il y en a d'autres
heureusement
ce qui permet de substituer son usage
par d'autres traitements
les traitements le standard of care
aujourd'hui en transplantation et assez
ancien il a une trentaine d'années et
par rapport à ces médicaments qui sont
majoritairement néphrotoxiques donc qui
ont une toxicité pour le greffon rénal
une des particularités du bellatasept
c'est de ne pas être toxique pour le
rein
d'améliorer la fonction des reins
transplantés mais aussi de diminuer la
survenue d'un certain nombre de
complications notamment de
l'hypertension artérielle et du diabète
qui sont très fréquentes avec les autres
traitements anti rejet et puis également
de prévenir la formation d'anticorps
dirigés contre le greffon qui sont en
fait les anticorps à l'origine des
rejets chroniques des greffes donc voilà
c'est particularité fonction médicament
un intérêt important pour une partie des
patients en tout cas
et c'est particularité ça fait donc 30
ans que qu'on les attendait que les
patients attendaient une avancée
thérapeutique de ce type là
le bellatasept est en pénurie en
situation de pénurie depuis 5 ans ça a
commencé par des tensions
d'approvisionnement et depuis deux ans
cette pénurie a des conséquences sur
vraiment sur l'accès des patients aux
médicaments qui se sont encore
criticisés ces derniers mois en gros
depuis l'été dernier
voilà et ces difficultés d'accès ont des
conséquences
importantes pour les patients alors un
dispositif a été mis en place pour
vraiment réguler l'attribution des
quelques doses de médicaments
aujourd'hui disponibles pour les
patients les plus urgents les plus
graves qui sont un petit nombre mais ces
indications qui ont été prévues laisse
de côté un certain nombre d'autres
indications du bellatasept qui pour
lesquels les patients sont vraiment en
attente de solution ça concerne
notamment les patients qui ont reçu un
rein de mauvaise qualité et
malheureusement comme vous le savez en
raison de la pénurie aujourd'hui un
nombre proportion important des patients
sont greffés avec des reins qu'on dit à
critères élargistes c'est-à-dire une
qualité un peu sub optimale voilà c'est
patients là en particulier
subissent beaucoup la néphrotoxicité des
traitements habituels et donc le
bellatasep pour eux à un intérêt majeur
et puis ça concerne aussi les patients
qui ont eu un rein de bonne qualité mais
qui se retrouve au bout d'un certain
temps altéré par la néphrotoxicité des
autres traitements et donc ce sont des
patients qui auraient besoin du
bellataccepte et il parviennent pas
aujourd'hui à y accéder
ce non accès à des conséquences très
concrètes c'est une dégradation plus
rapide du Rhin greffé
proportionnelle à la durée de non
recours et donc qui est vraiment
directement corrélée à la pénurie et
donc des pertes de chances associées qui
sont déjà majeurs avec des greffons
rénaux qui auraient dû être sauvés ou
améliorée qui aujourd'hui continuent de
se dégrader et risque d'être perdu au
bout de quelques mois alors que la durée
de vie de ces reins de ces greffes
auraient pu aurait pu être prolongée
perdre son greffon quand on est
transplanté ça veut dire retourner en
dialyse donc les conséquences humaines
et médicales elles sont évidemment
considérables pour les patients elles
sont également considérables pour le
système de santé puisque vous le savez
sans doute la dialyse un traitement
beaucoup plus coûteux pour la société
que la greffe de façon très schématique
une année de dialyse ça coûte 80 000
euros au système de santé une année de
pose greffe c'est 20.000 euros donc
voilà les conséquences de cette pénurie
c'est elles sont très mesurables pour
les patients et pour la société
alors aujourd'hui la situation c'est que
toutes les équipes en France n'utilisent
pas le Bel atacep de manière équivalente
et ça je dirais que c'est assez
indépendant de la pénurie certaines ne
l'utilisent pratiquement pas mais
d'autres l'utilisent beaucoup et sont
devenus très expertes dans son maniement
et aujourd'hui dans ces équipes expertes
ce qui se passe c'est que il existe des
listes d'attentes d'accès au
belattaccept voilà on travaille
notamment avec l'équipe de du CHU de
Grenoble
et à Grenoble il y a actuellement 150
patients grefféréaux qui sont en attente
en liste d'attente de bellata 7 et ça ça
se retrouve de façon assez générale sur
le territoire sont des patients qui
savent qu'ils devraient bénéficier de ce
médicament qui pourrait améliorer leur
santé et qui attendent qu'ils puissent
le rétratribuer voilà qui attendent que
la pénurie permette qu'il le reçoivent
voilà donc face à cette situation on a
été évidemment très impliquée dans dans
les démarches de gestion de la pénurie
donc un système de gestion a été mis en
place sur les indications les plus
graves mais qui laisse de côté comme je
le disais beaucoup de patients
ce que ce que demande notre association
c'est ça concerne plusieurs éléments
d'abord les transparence sur les raisons
de cette pénurie qui qui dure depuis
bientôt 6 ans on a du mal à comprendre
comment un industriel peut laisser cette
situation perdurer aussi longtemps
compte tenu de ses conséquences pour les
malades l'origine de la pénurie c'est un
changement d'usine c'est la mise en
place d'une nouvelle usine c'est un
biomédicament donc une chaîne de
production un peu complexe voilà et tout
a commencé par ce changement d'usine qui
aurait dû permettre d'améliorer la
production et de produire davantage en
fait on ne comprend pas pourquoi au bout
de six ans ce n'est toujours pas le cas
alors tous les ans le laboratoire nous
dit que dans un an ça ira mieux et en
fait c'est pas le cas dans un an ça pas
mieux donc voilà on est très sceptique
sur les capacités d'améliorer la
situation comme ça nous l'a à nouveau
été promis d'ici la fin de l'année 2023
voilà on souhaiterait également que
l'ampleur des pertes de chances que j'ai
un peu décrite soit clairement documenté
parce que c'est faisable de mettre des
données pour mesurer ces pertes de
chances concrètement on demande aussi
que les autorités sanitaires françaises
et européenne parce que l'Europe a
évidemment son rôle à jouer dans cette
histoire joue pleinement leur rôle et et
un site je dirais plus qu'un site face
en sorte que les industriels soient
tenus de produire leurs médicaments en
quantité adaptée à la demande des
patients
voilà et puis il y a des choses très
très concrètes sur le terrain qui
pourrait être mise en place et qui ne le
sont pas pour améliorer cette pénurie
d'abord de façon récente les autorités
de santé européenne le ma suite à la au
changement de chaîne de production pour
des questions de bio équivalence à
recommander une augmentation la
posologie de belatta 7 de 20%. c'est
important ça ça amplifie la pénurie
parce qu'il faut plus de doses pour le
même patient or les autorités de santé
américaines confrontées aux mêmes
données n'ont pas appris cette décision
donc nous on s'interroge sur la raison
de cette divergence entre les autorités
de France françaises enfin européenne et
américaine et gagner 20% de posologie
c'est à dire revenir à l'ancien dosage
s'il s'avère que les autorités
américaines ont pris cette décision pour
des raisons valables ça nous semblerait
déjà un progrès important pour disposer
de dos supplémentaires
on souhaiterait aussi qu'il y ait une
réelle gestion de la pénurie afin
d'optimiser les doses disponibles
aujourd'hui un patient qui pèse 50 kg
doit recevoir
300 mg de bellatasep tous les mois et le
médicament est conditionné en flacon de
250 mg donc pour 300 mg il faut 2
flacons un pour 250 1 pour 50 et les 200
mg restant sont aujourd'hui jetés voilà
perdu alors qu'on est en pénurie donc
nous nous incitons enfin nous avons
dialogué de façon très intense avec la
NSM pour permettre que les doses soient
préconditionnées et que on utilise le
dosage exact dont un patient a besoin et
qu'on ne jette pas les reliquats qui
soient utilisés collectivisés pour tous
les patients qui en ont besoin voilà
tout le monde semble prouver que c'est
une bonne idée et malgré ça ça n'avance
pas le sujet n'avance pas et on reste on
reste en pénurie voilà rien ne bouge sur
ce plan là et puis il y a un autre
élément qui pourrait être qui pourrait
être étudié de près c'est le recours à
l'espacement des doses en fait un
certain nombre d'équipes
regardent depuis plusieurs années ce qui
se passe si au lieu de faire l'injection
toutes les quatre semaines on l'a fait
toutes les six semaines il y a un
certain nombre d'études de données qui
montrent que ça se passe ça se passe
bien que si on sélectionne bien les
patients pour lesquels on espace ça ne
ça ne pose pas de risque particulier
mais aujourd'hui cette cette espècement
des doses n'est absolument pas prévu ni
encourager dans les mesures de gestion
de la pénurie là aussi ça permet très de
disposer plus de dos hein voilà et
peut-être aussi de d'éviter pour
certains patients la surexposition aux
produits en espérant un peu l'exposition
voilà donc tous ces éléments là on en
discute évidemment régulièrement avec la
NSM on trouve que les choses pourraient
avancer davantage pourraient avancer
plus vite pour trouver des solutions
concrètes et rapides pour les patients
j'ajouterai que les équipes qui
s'engagent dans ce pré conditionnement
ou dans l'espacement des doses ou dans
toutes ces mesures de gestion de la
pénurie ne n'y sont pas du tout incités
puisque on pourrait croire que ça leur
permettrait de récupérer du médicament
pour leur propre patient mais depuis la
mise en place des mesures de gestion de
la pénurie
les doses récupérées sont nationalisées
misopo commun et donc elle ne les
récupère pas pour leur propre patient ce
qui constitue dans les faits un vrai
désincitatif à mieux gérer la pénurie
localement
voilà voilà je voulais vous faire part
un peu de cette vision de notre
association de patients de ce que de
l'expérience des malades qui sont
aujourd'hui en attente de belattasept et
qui souhaiterait que des solutions
soient trouvées pour leur permettre un
accès plus rapide dans l'intérêt de leur
santé merci beaucoup
Merci à VOUS 5 pour le vos propos qui
nous permettent bien sûr d'éclairer nos
travaux
néanmoins c'est une commission d'enquête
nous sommes de sénateurs passionnés par
le sujet dont nous avons un certain
nombre de questions à vous poser afin de
répondre à nos interrogations dans un
premier temps je vais passer à la parole
à notre collègue rapporteur Laurence
Cohen qui est à ma droite je vous
propose de répondre à ces questions et
puis dans un deuxième temps je ferai
passerai bien sûr la parole à mes
collègues comme l'unité de temps est
assez importante je tenais à vous
préciser que nous avons pas pris une
trentaine de minutes pour cet échange
puisque nous avons rejoindre ensuite à
15h nos traditionnelle question
gouvernement
oui merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames et messieurs vous avez déjà
balayé pas mal de questions qu'on
pouvait qu'on pouvait se poser moi
j'aimerais avoir quelques
éclaircissements alors notamment
professeur Luc frima quand vous nous
parlez par exemple concernant la pénurie
de belatta 7 de du rôle de la de la
l'Agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament et notamment de la
constitution d'un comité d'experts de
trois personnes si j'ai bien suivi
j'aimerais bien savoir quelle est cette
organisation c'est à dire que une fois
que cette mini société savante ou
d'experts se réunit quelles sont les
décisions qui en découlent et comment
est-ce qu'elles après elles sont
éventuellement appliquées donc ça c'est
une question très très précise à vous à
vous de manière de manière ciblée vous
avez pratiquement tout et tous répondu
sur le moment où vous avez été confronté
à à des pénuries et on bien et en tout
cas c'est l'objet aussi de notre
commission d'enquête ça n'est pas un
phénomène récent d'un phénomène qui a
été amplifié notamment avec la crise
mais qui dure depuis un moment et
nous-mêmes en tant que sénateur et
sénatrice vous avez pu voir qu'il y
avait eu beaucoup de rapports
parlementaire bien fourni bien documenté
pas seulement au Sénat aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale sans que rien de
décisif ce produit hélas hélas par la
suite j'aimerais peut-être avoir votre
votre sentiment parce que vous avez été
plusieurs à dire que effectivement ces
pénuries ont des conséquences
extrêmement graves et notamment en
termes de perte de chance par rapport
aux patients que vous pouvez que vous
pouvez suivre je trouve votre
vos apports extrêmement importants parce
que hier j'avais posé cette question là
à Monsieur Jérôme Salomon qui est donc
le directeur général
de la santé qui avait pas vraiment
répondu à cette question en termes de
perte de chance c'est-à-dire qu'une fois
qu'on a constaté ça de faire un bilan
global et de prendre les décisions
adéquates donc est-ce que pour vous
notamment parmi les responsabilités il y
a effectivement le besoin que toutes les
agences prennent les leurs que ce soit
au niveau français ou au niveau européen
comme vous venez de le dire Madame mais
est-ce que vous considérez que les
laboratoires français ont une part de
responsabilité dans cette dans cette
pénurie et de quel ordre exactement vous
le vous le pensez donc du coup
quels sont les solutions parce que on
est là pour faire un constat mais des
constats je crois que là quel que soit
nos familles politiques on partage ces
constats mais maintenant il faut trouver
des solutions pour en sortir donc
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez il y a eu
un certain nombre de pistes qui ont été
effectivement à l'instant ouverte par
l'association rénalo mais c'est vrai
qu'on est un peu enfin moi je suis un
peu dubitatif quand j'entends des
solutions qui me semblent être
pardonnez-moi de bon sens là c'est pas
besoin pour moi il va besoin que le
législateur intervienne et puis vous
dites bah oui mais c'est peut-être de
bon sens mais en fait ça bouge pas d'un
iota pardonnez-moi l'expression un peu
familière donc quels sont vos
propositions et comment on peut on peut
les mettre les mettre en oeuvre et puis
vous avez parlé évidemment du rôle de la
France et de l'Europe c'est vrai qu'on
sent bien on a là au niveau au niveau
mondial on a à peu près les mêmes les
mêmes phénomènes de pénurie partout mais
en même temps ce sont les mêmes
politiques qui sont impliqués dans dans
tout dans tous les pays donc c'est pas
tellement étonnant mais est-ce que
justement dans vos contacts
professionnels soit en tant que médecin
soit en tant que responsable
d'associations
envisager est-ce que les échanges que
vous avez avec vos confrères ou le
personnel médical à l'étranger
au travers de ces échanges est-ce que il
y a exactement les mêmes choses ou
est-ce qu'il y a des solutions qui sont
mises en œuvre ailleurs et qui
pourraient être mis en oeuvre en France
je pense que c'est important pour
qu'au-delà donc des constats je le
répète on arrive quand même à des à des
solutions qui nous permettent en tout
cas au niveau de notre commission
d'enquête de de faire des propositions
beaucoup plus fortes voilà je vous
remercie
je réponds en premier donc puisque vous
m'avez posé la question donc le comité
d'experts comporte six experts 3 de la
sfndt trois de la Société Francophone de
transplantation donc c'est six experts
donc le groupe constitué par la NSM
au-delà du comité d'experts à établi
trois indications prioritaires et donc
à partir d'une fiche qui est complétée
donc par les
médecins dans leur service cette fiche
est adressée au laboratoire concerné qui
soumet la fiche au comité d'experts
lequel le comité d'experts sur la
description des éléments qui sont sous
ses yeux confirment ou non s'il y a
indication dans le cadre des trois
indications retenues à prescrire ou pas
le médicament donc c'est quelque chose
qui a été établi de façon très
rigoureuse scientifique et qui jusqu'à
présent a permis de répondre aux
demandes avec actuellement un potentiel
de prescription qui est supérieur à la
demande sur ces trois indications
je sais pas si j'ai répondu complètement
à votre question
en fait pour bien bien comprendre c'est
c'est après une réflexion donc de ces
experts le fait de cibler trois
indications pour pouvoir être au plus
près
comme prioritaire par rapport à d'autres
indications qui sont un petit peu plus
au second plan d'accord
les indications second plan ce sont
celles qui ont été
énumérer il y a quelques instants les
situations de greffon limite qui
nécessitent de recourir à des
médicaments qui sont le moins des front
toxiques possible
puisque j'ai la parole je vais continuer
sur la perte de chance pour le chant de
la néphrologie la dialyse et de la
transplantation la notion de perte de
chance et c'est quelque chose qui a été
débattu lors de la dernière réunion avec
la NSM et extrêmement difficile à
définir en réalité quand vous prescrivez
un médicament vous devez tenir compte de
très nombreux éléments de confusion
potentielles par exemple le greffon
assez caractéristique chaque patient est
un risque immunologique propre etc etc
donc pour considérer que la perte de
chance est du uniquement aux médicaments
c'est vraiment une un travail de longue
haleine en profondeur qui est qui est
difficile à mener ça a été mené par
l'Agence de la biomédecine qui dispose
de registres de dialyse et de
transplantation ça a été de mener sur
d'autres domaines que le celui du
bellatasept il y a quelques années c'est
une des références que je vous ai
adressé ce matin et qui a montré qu'il
n'y avait pas de risque avec un
dialyseur par rapport à d'autres
dialyseurs risques avaient été suspectés
à un moment donné donc voilà je pense
que la notion de perte de chance pour ce
qui concerne les maladies rénales
chroniques et de définition délicate et
ça doit être
utilisé avec prudence
oui alors donc les les pénuries
date de une bonne vingtaine d'années
entre temps les firmes pharmaceutiques
ont beaucoup changé en fait il y a eu
des phénomènes de mondialisation il y a
eu une sous-traitance accélérée
notamment de la production de matières
premières en Inde et en Chine comme on
le sait avec donc des tensions
structurelles mais parfaitement
prévisibles et des firmes ont fait ça
pour améliorer leur marge
financières ce qui est certain c'est
qu'en 20 ans les marges sont devenues de
plus en plus en fait des des outils de
la financarisation
et donc une recherche de
d'attractivité sur les marchés
financiers
qui fait que clairement c'est pas dans
leur modèle d'affaires aujourd'hui
devant des médicaments pas chers elle
dépend de essentiellement de médicaments
pas forcément vendus en très grande
quantité mais à des prix très élevés et
sont plus du tout dans une logique de
production de masse à des prix plus bas
donc en fait c'est une usine de produits
de luxe en fait c'est c'est clairement
ça qui s'est passé sous nos yeux et donc
les autorités présenté par rapport à ça
elles peuvent pas grand chose en fait
c'est un fait donc alors ce qui est
clair c'est que les titulaires
d'autorisation de mission de marché ils
ont une obligation selon la directive
2083 ce Article 81 de d'assurer le fait
d'approvisionner le marché c'est une
obligation européenne auquel en fait
elle ne satisfont pas et de moins en
moins donc il y a quand même beaucoup de
moyens d'essayer de leur faire respecter
cette obligation alors pour ceux qui
sont encore commercialisés par ces
firmes comme le bellasept
alors les autorités en France ont prévu
d'abord que les firmes soient tenus
d'informer à l'avance de pénurie de ou
de tension puis de mettre en place des
plans de gestion et pénurie très bien
puis de constituer des stocks de plus en
plus importants et assorti de sanctions
donc ça c'est très bien il faut le faire
et si au niveau européen on peut aller
vers ça parce que pour l'instant c'est
pas le cas ce sera très bien vraiment
pousser pour ça dans le cas de la
stratégie pharmaceutique qui va être
prochainement la fin mars normalement
publier donc ça il faut le faire c'est
absolument indispensable de viser les
firmes à respecter cette cette
responsabilité cela étant les firmes
aujourd'hui a pas de moyens les empêcher
d'arrêter à commercialisation du jour au
lendemain comme hier assez las avec
l'âge je vous assigne dommage
il y en aura plus à la fin du mois de
mars voilà que peuvent faire les deux
variétés en France rien juste dire merci
à stellas voilà on va se déployer
autrement
donc ça c'est la conséquence de pénurie
sur l'amoxicilline etc donc c'est déjà
d'autres cartes en fait donc pénurie sur
un médicament il y a un report vers la
justice je dessine ils avaient prévu un
stock qui durait un an résultat c'est un
mois voilà donc par rapport à ça il faut
vraiment envisager la possibilité
d'avoir des si vraiment il y a des
médicaments essentiels comme ceux dont
on a parlé tout à l'heure au bout de 7
ans l'affirme se révèle incapable de le
faire soit on l'oblige à le faire on
doit trouver des moyens soit il faut
envisager les productions publiques
comme ça a été proposé au niveau
européen en particulier par un organe du
Parlement européen qui a fait un travail
tout à fait intéressant mentionnant
l'intérêt d'un établissement public
aussi pour l'aspect recherche parce que
cette finance et la relation des firmes
pharmaceutiques fait aussi que un
certain nombre de médicaments en fait
n'intéresse pas les firmes hier encore
où il y a quelques jours
a dit qu'en fait ils arrêtaient de
travailler sur les maladies rares
évidemment a gagné des dizaines de
milliards de dollars sur le vaccin covid
comment voulez-vous que ça intéresse de
faire quelque chose qui rapporte
seulement même 10 millions d'euros pour
eux ça n'a aucun sens enfin de là voilà
donc il faut trouver des solutions
alternatives ce sera forcément que ce
soit public ou privé c'est forcément
européen parce qu'il faut rentrer dans
des logiques en fait de d'économie
d'échelle et puis de pour que ça quand
même un sens économique de produire ses
médicaments probablement envisager des
prix plus élevés de médicaments
essentiels parce que c'est vrai que
de rembourser les médicaments moins cher
que le coût de production enfin ça n'a
pas de sens les différents exemples qui
ont été dotés par ce panel là c'est
quand même c'est contre le bon sens le
problème c'est que ça dure depuis des
années quelque chose qui est contre le
bon sens depuis des années c'est quand
même un problème un petit peu structurel
donc
imaginez des revarisations sous une
forme ou sous une autre c'est pas
forcément sur le prix nominal du
médicament ça peut être de toute façon
de valoriser ces activités là mais donc
il faut avoir tout un panel de de
solutions et je terminerai en disant que
il faut aussi veiller à ce que si on
imagine une un établissement public qui
serait chargé de faire des médicaments
essentiels qui vraiment n'intéressent
pas du tout les chiens pharmaceutiques
dans leur modèle d'affaires aujourd'hui
et ben il faut aussi quand même imaginer
que ces médicaments là soient diffusés
dans le système parce qu'on peut très
bien imaginer et on en discutait tout à
l'heure avant la séance là d'avoir en
fait on l'a vu clairement dans le covid
avec des
usines de masques françaises qui se
mettent en route pour approvisionner le
marché français et puis quelques mois
après elle ferme parce que plus personne
n'en achète en France voilà donc on sera
confronté à cette situation là de
prévoir vraiment toute la chaîne de
valeur de de ces médicaments mais il
faut vraiment
regarder beaucoup de médicaments anciens
ici ont été cités des médicaments
essentiels or on a l'impression
aujourd'hui que les politiques
pharmaceutiques sont uniquement centrées
sur les médicaments de demain et ça
c'est une erreur est-ce qu'en 2023 il y
a énormément de médicaments très
intéressants qui sont très anciens et
dont on a toujours besoin il faut
aujourd'hui on a fait un déséquilibre
total et ça se sent au niveau des contes
de la sécurité sociale c'est qu'il y a
tellement besoin d'argent pour les
nouveaux médicaments que en fait il y en
a plus assez pour des médicaments plus
anciens donc il faut revoir
l'ensemble de ces de ces aspects si on
veut trouver des solutions pour faire
que les patients et accès aux
médicaments dont ils ont besoin qu'ils
soient chers pas cher anciens récent
c'est pas le problème c'est les
médicaments qui correspondent à des
besoins sanitaires merci
en termes de de proposition et puis pour
pour justement trouver des solutions et
comme cela a été dit d'ailleurs il
paraît important de pouvoir prévoir un
prix plancher pour ces médicaments pour
pour éviter le disparition et cela
semble vraiment un sujet un sujet majeur
et important il y a aussi une et ça a
été évoqué plusieurs fois une nécessité
de d'améliorer le pilotage en fait du
sujet sans doute il y a une tasse force
qui doit être qui doit être créée avec
et qui avait concertation avec les
parties prenantes puisqu'il y a des
choses on va dire de
prévention justement la fin des actions
de prévention des pénuries qui peuvent
être mises en oeuvre ça a été évoqué par
par plusieurs d'entre nous
de définition de seuil d'alerte par
produit et que cette information de
solidaire soit transmise le plus en
amont possible
par par les laboratoires à la NSM et que
l'information et puis cette mise à
disposition
aux différents acteurs dans le cadre
d'une base de données il y a des outils
qui que l'on peut mettre en place pour
améliorer le pilotage déjà de ces sujets
et de la pénurie
ensuite un autre sujet c'est la
définition même des médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutique majeur on peut
sans doute aller plus finement dans
cette définition si vous voulez plus
finement que la classe thérapeutique on
s'intéressant au dosage aux formes et
donc comme ça avoir une granularité
supplémentaire qui permet de ne pas
louper en fait de
sujets et de et de pouvoir être plus fin
et donc forcément
d'améliorer notre capacité collective
d'action également bien sûr il faut
renforcer les obligations concernant les
laboratoires sur ces sujets aujourd'hui
il y a une obligation quand un
laboratoire répond à un marché d'avoir
un plan de de gestion de la pénurie mais
cette obligation n'est pas accompagnée
vraiment de enfin de sanctions si le
l'applique pas et ils sont
insuffisamment précis en fait et donc du
coup cela n'a pas forcément l'utilité
qui est escompté et on pourrait aller
plus loin dans l'obligation que l'on
demande en précisant justement ce plan
quelles sont les modalités de prévenance
et d'anticipation les modalités de conjo
contingentement les interlocuteurs et
puis la sortir de sanctions
financières claires si ce n'est pas si
ce n'est pas respecté enfin pour pour
aller de manière rapide il y a des
exemples et pour répondre à votre
question sur
la comparaison avec ce qui se fait dans
d'autres pays en fait
c'est vrai que on peut travailler sur le
fait de prévoir des solutions pour les
produits pour lesquels aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de solution
d'approvisionnement stable de manière
récurrente et
prendre le relais avec la production de
avec la fabrication de préparation
hospitalière selon des bonnes pratiques
il y a l'exemple notamment aux
États-Unis de Civica un regroupement
structure universitaire qui qui permet
de faire cela et c'est sans doute
effectivement une des actions à mettre
en œuvre
enfin effectivement l'important c'est à
la fois au niveau français mais encore
plus européen de d'avoir un des stocks
tournants de deux mois sous la
responsabilité des laboratoires
qui permettent de faire tampon en cas de
tension et qui pourrait être également
une obligation qui leur est demandé
on fait dans l'ordre tout a été dit du
pilotage à la souveraineté aux
obligations
peut-être un petit peu plus de
visibilité dans dans tout ce qui se dit
sur les pénuries et sur les tensions
d'approvisionnement en fait on est
nourris beaucoup par les médias pas mal
par les rapports j'ai lu très vite hier
soir le rapport le Livre blanc de
l'Académie de pharmacie qui donne
énormément de solutions quand tout
d'ailleurs été proposées ici
la lisibilité ça tient aussi aux
classifications quand on regarde la
liste ATC on retrouve pas nos
spécialités
quand on compare entre société savante
sur quel médicament nous travaillons
donc j'en ai fait l'expérience minute
avec Monsieur frema on se retrouve sur
plusieurs listes ATC ça ne correspond
pas aux soins ça ne correspond pas au
processus de soins donc peut-être plus
de lisibilité et ça rentre un petit peu
dans le paquet de
pilotage et informations avec l'ensemble
des partenaires pour prendre des
justement ces décisions
l'étranger
on a été nourri par toute la
l'actualité nord-américaine en ce qui
concerne les tensions et les pénuries
puisque il y a 20 ans ils étaient déjà
dans une situation mais là dans un
marché déréglé où il cherchait des
solutions ce qu'on a pu observer c'est
que on n'a pas trop ils n'ont pas plus
trouvé de solution mais en tout cas on a
pu anticiper les problèmes donc on a pu
profiter de leur expérience mais il y a
pas de solution si ce n'est que à un
moment l'état américain le gouvernement
américain a pris des décisions justement
sur les sur les matières premières et
sur ces listes et de d'où la liste la
FDA qui a été produite à ce moment-là de
façon à rétablir une forme de contrôle
et souveraineté alors est-ce que c'est
national ou européenne je pense qu'il va
falloir un moment discuter avec nos nos
partenaires européens
s'agit-il d'aller faire une
réglementation qui utilisera le la
proposition la moins disante en Europe
je l'espère pas mais néanmoins c'est une
discussion européenne obligatoirement
sinon on va rétablir la Pharmacie
centrale des hôpitaux et je pense que
c'est la pire des mesures il faut que
d'une certaine façon elle soit partagée
par nos partenaires européens donc il
faut déjà qu'on fasse une proposition
française
alors j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure des
solutions très concrètes pour le
bellatasept mais je pense qu'on peut
réfléchir avec un peu plus de hauteur
sur ce que implique cette histoire et
toutes les autres dont on a entendu
parler
en termes de désintérêt de l'industrie
pharmaceutique pour un certain nombre de
produits de médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeur
le bellatasept d'ici trois ans il
passera dans le domaine public donc nous
nous sommes assez inquiets en fait du
désengagement de BMS qui se traduit
notamment par cette pénurie sans fin et
par l'incapacité aujourd'hui de nos
autorités sanitaires de forcer BMS à
assurer la production adéquate de son
médicament donc je pense qu'en termes de
réflexion on peut regarder ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis ou plus d'un
millier d'établissements de santé qui
était lassés des difficultés de gestion
de pénurie de médicaments ce sont
organisés sous la forme une structure
coopérative pour pour
réorganiser la production de médicaments
d'intérêt thérapeutiques majeurs à prix
coûtant donc c'est une expérience qui
existe ça s'appelle Civica Erics et on
pourrait imaginer que en France voir en
Europe il y ait la création d'un
établissement français ou européen du
médicament dont ce soit la mission
finalement de l'établir des partenariats
publics privés avec des acteurs qui
aujourd'hui sont impliqués dans la
production de médicaments pour imaginer
une production de médicaments d'intérêts
thérapeutique majeur après coûtant et
non profite de façon à la fois
relocaliser l'ensemble de la production
en Europe et puis à assurer un accès aux
patients qui ne soit pas entachés par
ces pénuries qui qui dépendent bien sûr
de l'engagement ou du désengagement des
industriels
merci pour vos réponses je vais passer
la parole à mes collègues avec avec
d'abord madame Müller Braun qui s'est
inscrit
merci mesdames et messieurs pour les
propos très intéressants mais aussi
inquiétant que que vous nous présentez
je rebondis sur votre dernière
intervention madame alors moi je viens
de Strasbourg et il y a le Parlement
européen et on est en contact avec des
parlementaires or au Parlement moi on
m'a fait savoir il y avait qu'il y avait
un rapport de d'une parlementaire
colline sterlay qui justement au niveau
du Parlement on pensait à créer cet
établissement public qui permettrait de
racheter donc des molécules qui sont pas
chères qui sont hors brevet et de
pouvoir les refabriquer au niveau
européen donc c'est quelque chose qui
est déjà proposé par certains
parlementaires et ce serait une solution
au moins pour vous nous avez expliqué
que les médicaments peu chers les
molécules peu chères qui n'intéressaient
plus les industriels étaient laissés
malheureusement de côté et c'est là que
la puissance publique européenne
forcément puisque il faudrait pas que ce
soit national on y arriverait pas mais
aurait un intérêt à se saisir et à
racheter donc et à refabriquer ces
molécules de base
je crois que ce serait peut-être
intéressant qu'on puisse se rapprocher
de ces de ses porteurs d'idées qui sont
au niveau du Parlement mais voilà c'est
des solutions qui semblent intéressantes
mais urgentes parce que quand on vous
entend
c'est très triste d'arriver à on a bien
entendu que ça fait plus de 20 ans que
la sonnette d'alarme est tirée qu'on a
vu certains ministres et beaucoup de
gens tiraient cette sonnette d'alarme et
qu'aujourd'hui encore ce mois-ci vous
dites il y a des médicaments qui
disparaissent
parce que je voulais exprimer merci
merci Laurence je vous propose avant de
d'y répondre peut-être juste que vous
écoutiez les questions de deux autres
collectionnatrices s'il s'agit de Madame
Grigny et de Madame Jacquemet puis après
je vous propose de répondre à mes trois
collègues
merci pour pour vos propos
moi je suis avec ma collègue Laurence
haribet à la commission des affaires
européennes sur justement l'Europe du
médicament et l'Union européenne en
matière de santé n'est pas une
compétence pleine mais une compétence
d'appui ce qui pose quand même des
difficultés quand il s'agit de la crise
comme on a vécu avec le covid des
victimes il y a eu on va dire une
meilleure collaboration mais c'est quand
même c'est quand même très très
compliqué dans ce cadre là on a été
sollicité par des groupements
fédérations de PME en fait le
laboratoire mais sous forme de PME de
petites entreprises françaises qui nous
ont dit le gros sujet ça reste l'ONDA
mais la clause de sauvegarde
et que tant qu'on aura pas ça de toute
façon la France elle ne sera pas
prioritaire par rapport aux entreprises
à moins d'étatiser effectivement là ce
sera autrement mais en revanche vous
pouvez pas d'ailleurs monsieur
professeur frema qui a parlé des
remboursements qui sont en dessous des
coups des coûts de revient aujourd'hui
ce que nous ont dit et on a reçu deux
fédérations sollicités par deux
fédérations nous ont dit que ce soit la
Chine ou l'Inde ils ont fait leur choix
de marcher et donc ils préfèrent ne pas
vendre en France donc derrière les
pénuries elles sont là et les princesses
y sont pas fait chez nous donc on est
relativement coincé la clause de
sauvegarde également donc ça le
gouvernement aujourd'hui ne répond pas
du tout à ses attentes là et assez
réponses là donc tant qu'on n'aura pas
fait ça enfin moins que vous me disiez
qui est qui est autre chose je pense
qu'on avancera pas nous on a proposé
aussi des stocks faire des stocks dans
des entreprises
ça a un coût qui porte le coup nous on
l'a proposé en disant que les États
devaient aider financièrement apporté le
coup des stocks qu'on pourrait exiger
sur sur les médicaments dit essentiels
critiques etc voilà
merci bonjour Merci pour vos propos moi
je voudrais revenir sur le petit
document qu'on nous a transmis et ce que
j'ai réussi à lire dans les propositions
que vous faites professeur frima vous
marquez éviter le gaspillage des
médicaments alors est-ce que vous pensez
que
distribuer les médicaments à l'unité
serait une solution pour lutter un peu
contre la pénurie moi je prends
l'exemple je suis vétérinaire et nous ça
fait des années voire des dizaines
d'années qu'on détaille les plaquettes
d'antibiotiques d'anti-inflammatoires en
fonction du poids de l'animal et de la
durée du traitement alors je suis
toujours étonnée que on fasse pas de
même pour la médecine humaine et puis
vous marquez aussi permettre une
réutilisation raisonnée des matériels
alors qu'est-ce que vous entendez par là
et voilà je trouve que ce sont des
mesures de bon sens merci
pour ce qui concerne le gaspillage c'est
ce que vous avez noté alors dans
quelques jours la sfndt publie un livre
blanc sur la dialyse verte et il y a une
dimension environnementale si on jette
10% 20% du médicament ce qui est pas
utilisé ça pollue et c'est vraiment du
gaspillage il y a aussi la problématique
c'est pas le médicament mais par exemple
un set de préparation pour la pose d'un
cathéter vous avez toujours
45% de matériel en trop dans le 7 ça a
été montré c'est c'est le pont vers le
réutilisable à partir du moment où on
considère qu'un dispositif et et jetable
on peut plus le réutiliser même si il a
pas été utilisé il y a peut-être tout un
champ de de réflexion à faire
on n'a pas besoin de compresse stérile
pour tous les soins par exemple vous
voyez c'est
c'est on est allé je sais que la Spar
propose de revenir à des blouses en
tissu pour ne plus utiliser ces blouses
jetables c'est on est un petit peu un
tournant on doit se remettre en cause
globalement par rapport à des normes
qu'on a qu'on a poussé
qui est-ce qui décide de ses normes
justement à quel niveau est-ce que ça
peut se retravailler ça parce que je
suis entièrement d'accord avec vous on
voit parfois des sept on prend une passe
une paire de ciseaux et puis tout le
reste ça part alors qui est-ce qui est
responsable de ces normes et à quel
niveau voilà justement est-ce qu'on peut
intervenir pour faire changer certaines
choses la composition des 7 enfin moi ça
fait plus de 30 ans que je suis
néphrologue historiquement c'était
l'établissement qui préparait les 7 avec
le matériel ça venait de l'Astérie la
stérilisation aujourd'hui c'est des sets
qui sont fournis par l'industriel avec
trop de matériel dedans donc je sais pas
s'il y a une norme par rapport à leur au
conditionnement mais on pourrait
réfléchir ensemble quoi enfin il y a
toute une dimension de de
comment dire d'ajustement de aux besoins
réels qui qui a pensé aussi quoi on peut
plus permettre de gaspiller aujourd'hui
monsieur Chirac vous l'a apporté une
réponse je voulais juste vous dire qu'il
reste à peu près 5 minutes donc si on
peut tout synthétiser
je ne sais pas parce que sur les 29 pays
concernés en Europe et tous ont des
pénuries de médicaments et donc il y a
pas d'ondes dans les autres pays donc je
ça fait partie souvent des propositions
un peu simpliste de certaines filles en
pharmaceutiques certes faudra imaginer
que certains médicaments soient plus
chers les médicaments anciens mais il
faut aussi des obligations et des
sanctions et la question du de la
délivrance à l'unité ça m'a fait penser
que peut-être pour un nouvel un argument
supplémentaire pour en fait rapatrier en
Europe de la production de matières
premières ou pour des questions de
souveraineté des questions
environnementales en fait c'est à dire
si on prend en compte l'empreinte
carbone d'une part et les pollution
liées à la production pharmaceutique et
bien il a assez clair que il faut aussi
rapatrier des productions
pharmaceutiques en Europe
et pas se débarrasser de ça dans des
pays tiers qui de toute façon enfin en
Chine aujourd'hui une pharmaceutique de
matière première ferme dans le cas de la
lutte contre la pollution en Chine il
faut bien avoir conscience de ça c'est
un des éléments de pénurie de
médicaments donc utilisons cet argument
politique de l'environnement et le le
fait de mieux respecter les normes
environnementales va de toute façon
entraîner un surcoût de médicaments
qu'il faut accepter
c'est tout
en 15 secondes
pour répondre à la question du riz
processing la réutilisation de
matérialisage unique l'Europe avait
proposé aux états de choisir entre des
politiques de riz processing ou pas et
en avril 2022 la France a répondu non
donc pas de réutilisation possible de
matériel à usage unique alors c'est
logique il y a un élément de sécurité
mais dans nos chez nos voisins allemands
allemands par exemple il y a toute une
industrie de riz processing de cathéter
de d'éléments ça touche beaucoup la
carte du interventionnelle mais
puisqu'on n'a pas le temps je vous
propose qu'on se contacte on a un comité
développement durable absolument
incroyable dans notre société qui s'est
intéressée à tous ces points là et qui
en ce qui concerne le gaspillage c'est
surtout les dispositifs médicaux en
revanche je suis pas sûr pour le
médicament que il y a vraiment du
quelque chose de d'extrêmement important
à gagner voilà
le financement c'est-à-dire de deux mois
de stock tournant par
les États pour les labos serait sans
doute quand même une solution
intéressante c'est une sorte d'avance
que l'on fait pour danse de trésorerie
quelque part que l'on fait et pour finir
effectivement sur le long terme c'est le
sujet que j'évoquais en préambule sur
les radiations par exemple et c'est vrai
que le fait d'avoir une loi de
programmation au pluriannuelle qui sort
de la réalité budgétaire et qui permet
d'avoir des priorités et de pouvoir les
confronter à des logiques budgétaires
plus annuelles et plus comptables et
sans doute quand même quelque chose de
majeur
merci est-ce que vous avez une réponse à
apporter à ma collègue sénatrice du
Bas-Rhin Laurence Muller Braun
concernant l'établissement public
oui c'est très bien de même que sivica
qui a été cité c'est à dire
collaboration entre voilà comme les
États-Unis mais en fait il faut utiliser
tout un tas de moyens mais effectivement
les pharmacies hospitalières peuvent
faire des médicaments et le font déjà
aux États-Unis en Pays-Bas dans d'autres
pays donc il faut voilà il faut
envisager tout un tas de possibilités il
y aura pas une solution unique je crois
que
mais ça fait partie effectivement des
solutions qui pourraient apporter sur
sur les expériences quand même que que
l'on a de qui sont diverses il y a des
expériences donc aux États-Unis ensuite
au Brésil avec la Fondation Oswaldo Cruz
voilà il y a des expériences qui sont
multiples et variées qui peuvent être
utilisés et je suis d'accord s'il y a
pas une solution mais il y a une
multitude de solutions mais déjà là dans
notre échange si on ressent si on va
recenser toutes les propositions que
vous avez pu faire on a quand même un
grand un grand choix de proposition
je vous propose aussi encore des
questions
je vous propose de lever la séance si
vous avez des informations de
transmettre individuellement aux
collectivement bien sûr
n'hésitez pas donc
voilà merci infiniment